die kriegssituation ich hoffe wenn ihr
das telefonieren und dezent sie aber der
zwischenzeit aus dem sap und sie sagen
dass gott ihn natürlich besser ist das
so richtig wenn ich das so zusammenfasst
worum geht's schlecht ist dass wir über
das thema redet oder einfach die
situation
können sie sagen also was du jetzt
gedrückt
ich wollte
im einsatz mit notfall psychiater martin
parr ist in besitz der dem mars lieder
auch im ausgang oder gar so doch also
pflicht jetzt nur wenige sisley das gibt
es wahrscheinlich wie viele andere war
leider auch also so ein samstag tritt
mit den nöten aber er hat es klappt viel
besser als andré höhne 1
seit man dann also mit teils wenig zeit
eine waldstrategie sie es aber doch
eigentlich trifft verlauf dass er mir
sind ungewollt zu geworden dass ich
glaube das hat sich ist laut martin
pauli wird zum menschen gerufen deren
innere welt aus den fugen geraten ist
wie bringt der notfall sicher wieder
ruhe in die gefühls- und gedanken in den
köpfen seiner patienten davon handelt
dieser fiel
[Musik]
24 stunden pike dienst mit tiefen
einblicken in lebens- und
leidensgeschichte liegen vor martin parr
23 wurde an einem donnerstagabend in der
stadt zürich bei der notfallzentrale
ärzte von hat sich eine mutter gemeldet
die von ihrem achtjährigen sohn
attackiert wurde
der junge hat das asperger syndrom wieso
ihn belastet und da muss jetzt menschen
sieht oder vielleicht für die letzten
tage sehr aggressiv orte sie unter sache
der wohnung demoliert
völlig ratlos was jetzt muss machen
der konflikt des heutigen abends statt
hausaufgaben zu machen will der junge
nach draußen in den nächsten schnee des
jahres diesen spaziergang will er sich
mit gewalt erkämpfen
das gespräch zwischen markt in paris
mutter und sohn darf ich ohne bild vom
treppenhaus aus aufnehmen
heiße paris wittstock soll heißen stuhl
plötzlich haben
in dem bestimmte aufgabe wundert es dass
die grundregel zusammenschnitt
[Musik]
was mich beschäftigt ich überhaupt gar
keine chance gegen überhaupt nur zu gut
wie unerreichbar axis egal was jetzt
noch ist wenn sie jetzt zeit okay es ist
jetzt ein doppeltes nein nur schnell
sondern herausstellte zurück ich muss
jetzt mal die aufgabenübertragung wer
hat sich denn wie die krank oder ich
dich denn der zug ist abgefahren
ja schwierig für holly vielleicht ein
quarter der stadt immer drin die seit 50
und nach abnehmen und das konnte diese
situation nicht besser oder 100 das habe
gefragt ob sie andere beispiel das
nachher im gespräch und dass gott und
wünsche viel kraft und erfolg im ganzen
martin paris wieder medikamente
verschreibe noch eine einweisung
veranlassen
trotzdem warstein erscheinen wichtig
wäre also darf endlich braucht motto es
ist wirklich vorgefallen
den finde ich silber und technologischer
und hoffe das gibt sich eine gewisse
entlastung und grüße hilft was denn die
nächsten schritte
und jetzt da auf um in burg zeigen sogar
dass noch etwas kommen rät einfach
kommentarlos hin dass er damit dem stark
davon dass nordfriesland zur sache
aber es gab immer dass ich so etwas nur
also sehr schwer weiß ist
psychiatrisches glücklich
unterschiedlich sagt sigrid mir leid
dass ich überhaupt nicht jan kopecky
office aus berga syndrom
und das heißt dass kommunikation ganz
massiv gestört aber vor antritt ist also
die die menschen sehen so sehr anders
und und leidet und wenn es immer wenn es
um das kind dort wo man muss hier wo man
sein tier ist die gesellschaft die führe
und genau das ist ja gesellschaft und
dann gab es für das bei der mensch das
größte problem ist eigentlich ein
widerspruch für sie zurück in der praxis
im zürcher stadtkreis 7 martin pauli
macht seit 28 jahren notfalldienst drei
mal pro monat immer 24 stunden am stück
daneben betreute hier in seiner
psychiatrischen praxis ein gutes dutzend
langzeitpatienten
die meisten seiner berufskollegen sind
froh dass sie freiwillig so häufig und
regelmäßig die für alle obligatorischen
und willige beliebten und fahrdienste
übernimmt mir graut einem notfall
windstoß ich mich zwar aber wenn es
fertig ist ein abschluss und nachher und
ein anderer fall
und die kann ich mich wieder vorne
setzte hingegen das jetzt sehr viele
patienten hat die wodurch viele yards um
ihre praxis können und ich musste so
umschaut das ist thema vom herr müller
und das vor der frau meier und sowie das
dunkle mich jetzt nur anstrengend dahin
verbringt sie jetzt die nacht wenn sie
nutzer die in stellt das war vor der
nacht übrig bleibt ja sind habe ich
nicht immer so folie und ganz sie nicht
da war es laut martin paris bett bleibt
ungenutzt
es ist halb zwei uhr in der nacht der
nächste einsatz in institutionen da
blickt ja was junge leute dort wo nicht
wo ja insgesamt bleibe probleme hat und
jetzt geht's um ein junger mann aus
eintracht gehört auch sehr unruhig
geschont und stört aber ob sie zum gott
das ist die andere stört oder das
erhofft guten weg ich muss mit der
kamera draußen bleiben
in dieser institution sind weder bild
noch ton aufnahmen erlaubt eine stunde
vergeht
ich stelle mir schon unschöne szenen vor
die eine zwangseinweisung vorangehen als
die ambulanz vorfeld doch das
zusammentreffen von arzt und patient
verlief ganz anders
er ist so aufmerksamkeit auf mopedklasse
so im schnitt sitzen ganz langsamkeit
und viele symbolische band kommt ist
ebenso über die bibel gestrichen und
vernetzung
figuren der luft zeichnet und ganz
langsam kriegt und ich eigentlich nie
rache ist voraus frage hätten hier
können bernd rothacker einzige wenn ich
seit das grottenschlechte was kann man
machen hätte es krieg ungerechtigkeit
auf der wand und dunkle macht wenn die
schlacht uns gibt einmal mit krücken
aber so vorstand hans los und gibt es
einen oktober frage wahrscheinlich
völlig inneren andere welt vermuten dass
er angst hat und am schluss etwa zum
glück aus dem sdax
und nicht nur zum beruhigen und auch
eine schlaufe sondern auch zum tanken
und wenn ich glück habe ich deine der
klinik gestellt haben jetzt wesentlich
besser rät und kaufrecht bis vor sich
sagen das ist jetzt fast allen plätzen
juristisch gesehen handelt es sich hier
um eine zwangseinweisung auch wenn sie
sehr ruhig verläuft der verwirrte
patient kann nämlich nicht einmal die
frage beantworten ob er freiwillig in
die klinik eintritt oder nicht
morgen am 4
entzieht stadtmitte nacht kann ja ja
sehr gefragt ist wirklich wie wenn sie
eine sandburg höre wird mir fühlt sich
bedroht
wer weiß der andere schlafen und ich war
die ursache oder folge plötzlich andere
auftauchen denkt man was macht denn die
letzten minister aus und am tag hält man
das gefühl vollkommen vergessen also
praktisch nie sr wahnsinn
das fragt was nicht mehr als aus
ich glaube nicht dass ich ein brand für
interessiert aber die stimmig so wie sie
bei ihm und den so ruhig und ganze
zerstört und betrauen
jetzt kann sich martin pauli in seiner
praxis hinlegen
der nächste einsatz kommt erst um halb
elf am nächsten morgen dann kann er
wieder durch punkt aber der kollege
was ist los das heimlich allgemeine
patient das ist glaub ich betreutes
wohnen wo psychische raum kriege dometic
galant und zum allgemeingut und obwohl
jetzt auch verboten wenn ich kann dann
nimmt das reh zwei wochen immer mehr
zurückzog und ist ein online battle
nachgab und kolleg wo in patient
regelmässig seht also die zwei wochen
zeit dass man wahrscheinlich nichts die
hospitalisierung machen wie in der
patient sowohl im sommer in der
situation sich aus alle tage schnitt
macht und den überraschend über
attackierte eine zwangseinweisung in die
psychiatrische klinik wird notwendig
eine sogenannte fürsorgerische
unterbringung ultima ratio für notfall
psychiater martin parr oberstes ziel
wird jetzt sein den patienten von einem
freiwilligen eintritt in die klinik zu
überzeugen
im gespräch mit dessen betreuerin
schwindet allerdings die hoffnung auf
eine einvernehmliche lösung oder am
anfang habe ich ihn sehr oft gesehen
ungefähr bis mitte dezember hat alles
gut geklappt hat regelmäßig arbeiten
gegangen
er ist regelmäßig arbeiten gegangen hat
megamind regenmesser genommen
doch jetzt regelmäßig ja das kann ich
schon sicher sagen arbeitet schläft
pausenlos ganzen tag schläft nachts
städte andere mitbewohnerinnen raus der
land gehe und sie direkte drucken also
erschlafft formen und da geht also
werden sich sagen dass die trasse
wichtig war ich hatte die hoffnung dass
er vielleicht würde wenige und seid ihr
oder eingegangen hat aber die chancen
sind gut
würde sie in weg dann sage dass sie in
new york sagte hält und den künsten ja
vielleicht frage ob er motorola oder
operiert wenn ich zu ihm ins zimmer
kommt damit ich kann mir das überhaupt
im folgenden gespräch muss die kameras
draußenbleiben
die stimmung im raum ist anfangs
aggressiv der patient fühlt sich von den
blödsinnigen fragen belästigt doch dann
die wende
gefragt nach seinen konkreten plänen für
die nächsten tage lenkte man ein und
stimmt eine einweisung zu hervor
es sind sie so ganz entspannt und
wirkungskraft sie sind doch überrascht
der überaus tatsache also einer sieht
sich der patient wachen sie als
befürchtet durch an drucke und einer fuß
leicht als eine art freiwillige klinik
gegangen
und sonderlich passierte richards
freiwillig kommen das ist natürlich der
best case soll ich finde richtig dass er
klinik wird und das ist viel besser wenn
er freiwillig
bei aller liebe zum notfalldienst martin
paris lebensmittelpunkt ist seine
familie die beiden kinder leona und
florian und seine frau das schicksal
wollte es dass es sehr spät vater wurde
martin parr ist 70 seine kinder acht und
zehn
ich möchte dir primär das spart die
vaterschaft ist schon nicht mehr gefahr
dass ich jetzt überhaupt kind und der
familie hat das analog aber muss sagte
es hat wie sie nach teil also wenn es so
wäre es vielleicht besser immer früher
nach älteren ist es für noch deine zum
beispiel china zähle also die
einzelpunkte irgendwie durch lichthupe
mit der arbeit und buch und noch die
unterstützung also durch hat auch eine
hoffe dass siedlung und was ich nicht so
weiß aber was möglich ist dass junge
energien und dann habe ich für euch ist
es so wenn kinderbett sinkt dann sehen
wir sehr gern auch schon weg zur großen
freude der kinder psychiater und tüftler
martin pauli ein fahrendes sofa gebaut
mit diesem gefährt pflegt familie pauly
an weiteren tagen ausfahrten in die
umgebung zu unternehmen
[Musik]
wenn sie nicht angst dass wenn jetzt
bevor ein patient ist das dir danke der
politik in folge ich will jetzt nicht
sagen könnte sie willigten sie die nach
dem vertrauen
wer weiß
[Musik]
es ist schon komisch leona ja ich weiß
es ist sofort ziemlich toll findet
[Musik]
martin paris pikettdienst neigt sich dem
ende zu um 18 uhr wird er zu jenem
einsamen mann gerufen der sich das leben
nehmen will
die polizei ist ausgerückt und versucht
den mann von seinem vorhaben abzubringen
jetzt wird es martin paris aufgabe sein
zu entscheiden wo wir den patienten vor
sich selber schützen und einweisen muss
oder ob dieser schritt nicht nötig ist
sie sind ganz auf sich allein gestellt
und sei zum teil ganz fit griffen die
konsequenz daraus sido entscheidet ja
stimmt
das tönt das wäre ein nachteil vor der
aufgabe
ich finde es eigentlich eher im vorteil
also umgekehrten aufgabenfülle wo kaufen
braucht es gar kein konsequent zeit dass
ich einfach langweilig und das motiviert
garnier und ich bin glücklich dort
umgekehrt wenn man weiß und rosa
dann nimmt sie hätte man zusammen und
nur nachts beste und das macht sie ja
auch spannend als martin parr in der
wohnung des lebens mythen mannes
eintrifft ist die polizei schon wieder
weg der notfall psychiatrie fährt dass
der patient unter verschiedenen ängsten
und phobien leidet und seit jahren in
psychiatrischer behandlung ist das was
ihr das problem ist ja
durch
was ist was passiert wenn sie denn
jemals dankt sie wetter bis unternehmen
immer noch erwähnt dass ihm einsätze
gewinne drin dass ich jetzt gibt jetzt
kommen indem sie den 350 menschen sorgen
dass so danke die wenigsten gut aber
leider gibt es existiert wirklich sehr
gerecht und sind das stimmt
märz zuvor gesagt das leben noch nichts
machen derzeit das land inzwischen und
jetzt ziemlich hinaus sind sie alle
das abkommen das recht für sich wirklich
zornig und dass er
märz musik frau gestellt steinheims
folge wird das wenn sie jetzt wieder
einig sind
ein kleines bisschen ordnung in einem
beängstigenden wirbel von gefühlen und
gedanken
martin paris einsatz scheint geglückt
wenn sich die hoffnung erfüllt dass er
jetzt besser ab telefoniere oder sogar
es fälle von stank und wo sie stäbe
nicht möglich sie wer dem finde ich dass
es mosaikstein lieber gut und nützlich
ist das ist auch nur schwer bis der
tatsächlich zur anderen
mit lienen erhielt sie ja gesagt es gibt
vielleicht einmal situationen wo man im
moment bis links schließt verhandelt
wurde nachher aber folgt wo bliebe also
mit weichen stellt gott das ja nur
gesamte miete überhaupt am schluss ich
dazu findet in rom sondern ihn anrufen
und der unterschied ganz am anfang sehr
schick sieht das gibt es ja nicht
aber oft machen halt mit vielen kleinen
schritten würden patienten
[Musik]